now zombies can live happy lives we hate
to break it to you Addison and Zed but
the good times are over for now you
might have ended zombies on a high note
but trouble is coming for you in zombies
- nice to meet you if you thought
uniting zombies and humans was hard wait
until the Disney Channel throws
werewolves into the mix just when you
thought you had it all figured out
we're sorry Addison and Zed but
something is coming for Seabrook hi and
it doesn't look pretty I could get in so
much trouble it's official you guys ssam
bees - is coming to a small screen near
you if you're as excited as we are you
probably want all the details but don't
worry we've got you covered
keep watching to find out which original
cast members will be reprising their
roles and which ones won't be all right
we'll have a zombie uprising force them
to make us equal we tear it all down
zombies fans have been asking for a
sequel ever since the Disney Channel
released a zombies in 2018 and it looks
like they're getting everything they
asked for and more
during the Disney Channel's descendants
three premiere a familiar logo flashed
across the screen promising fans a
sequel to Addison and Ed's star-crossed
love story the teacher doesn't give us
much information which is why fans are
curious to find out what zombies 2 has
in store for them we don't get to see
any of our favorite characters
throughout the short teaser but it spec
is undeniable so when can we expect to
see zombies - well there isn't an exact
date set just yet but we do know that
the sequel will air sometime in 2020 if
there's one thing fans picked up on
throughout the teaser trailer it's
scratch marks which can only mean one
thing
werewolves but we'll explain how
werewolves fit into the sequel in just a
moment for now let's take a look at how
zombies left off and why our heroes are
in for another groundbreaking semester
the Seabrook community had been divided
for half a century before Addison and
Zed came along well how would you know
you're perfect they were from opposite
sides of the tracks with
Sabeena human and dead being a zombie
but their adversary never stood a chance
in the presence of love Addison and Z's
Union caused the students of Seaver Kai
to unify and create a brand new world
zombies ends with the promise of a
happily ever after Addison and Zed
confess their love for one another and
later on everyone goes to zombie town to
enjoy a good old-fashioned block party
despite the movie ending on a high note
lucky things can change
it looks like Seabrooks newfound unity
is about to be challenged once again
some in other words there's going to be
trouble in paradise comes aam be Stu the
Disney Channel has released some
important information about the sequel
they've confirmed that Zed in Edison are
going to be returning to see Burke High
where they'll continue to help their
classmates and communities strive toward
unity and equality but instead of
focusing on human and zombie
relationships see Burke high will have
to cope with the arrival of a new and
puzzling group of werewolves instead of
practicing what they preach many zombies
and humans are going to clash with the
werewolves they're going to fight with
the newcomers and close their minds off
to change despite being the best couple
ever Addison and dead aren't going to
see eye to eye when it comes to
werewolves attending Seabrook High and
that's going to cause a rift between the
star-crossed lovers we're hoping that
the people of Seabrook and a zombie town
will be able to open up their hearts
once more after all werewolves need love
too but for now it looks like the
zombies and werewolves are going to
clash big time being like just so weird
the sequel just wouldn't be the same
without Addison and Dead who are played
by Meg Donnelly and Milo Manheim
respectively so it makes total sense
that these two are reprising their roles
but what about their go-to pals Kylee
Russell is set to return as Eliza and
Trevor Tordjman isn't done with Bucky
just yet
Carla Jeffery is returning as breathe
and James Godfrey is reprising his role
as Bonzo and let's not forget about
Kingston Foster who plays the one and
only Zooey the main squad is back and
ready for action
but there are a few new faces on board
that are sure to cause a stir three
teenage werewolves are going to be at
the front line of their clan say hello
to wolfy siblings Willa and Wyatt who
are played by Chandler Kinney and Pierce
josa
wrists
effectively and let's not forget about
their pack mate winter who's portrayed
by Arielle Martin these three werewolves
are going to change the way things are
done at Seabrook high forever so don't
let them out of your sight by now it's
no secret that Milo Manheim wanted there
to be a zombies - he's tweeted about it
more than once and his dreams are coming
true
well think about it so we were more than
a little surprised to find out the
Disney Channel had already wrapped up
production for zombies - Milo posted
this picture to his Instagram account in
it we see the main cast acting silly
side by side but it's Milo's caption
that says it all
the actor confirms that zombies - has
been wrapped up making us even more
excited for 2020 but we make him look
pretty cool
Milo also took the time to post an
adorable picture of him and Meg on a
rooftop terrace he calls Meg his baby
while wishing her a happy 19th birthday
we can't wait to see their on-screen
chemistry come to life once more on the
small screen oh I meant
welcome to the cafeteria thanks who else
is excited for zombies to sound off in
the comments and don't forget to tell us
who your favorite character is while
you're at it thanks for watching don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to our Channel
we'll see you next time on the things
[Music]